[Applause]
tonight Leonardo DiCaprio through the
decades now you have my attention only
et's been there since his Showbiz start
I did my first television commercial
when I was 13 from his Hollywood Growing
Pains this is TV Big Show to his Titanic
size startup from the king of the
world king of the world um never live
that one down for the first time never
before seen interviews he's great behind
the scenes of his 30 won films Leo on
roles he turned down and the one that
finally got him his Oscar I think people
are going to be talking about that
sequence for a while plus why despite
having a list of high-profile romances
he's only gone red carpet official twice
I have a girlfriend right now
Entertainment Tonight presents ET Vault
unlocked Leonardo DiCaprio you can't
exactly put that on the the title for et
can
you Leonardo DiCaprio This is Your Life
welcome to Entertainment Tonight and
this this is why the ET vault is the
gift it just keeps on giving yes it does
because no show has been with him from
the jump like ET and now we are
unlocking all of Leo's Hollywood
eras I feel extremely lucky every day
and I feel like I hit the lottery and I
I don't I don't take it for granted I'm
the king of the
world Oscar winner activist it's
important for people to give back king
of Charisma you have the most beautiful
eyes I have ever seen Leo always daddy
with ET has watched his movies gross
over $6 billion at the box office I feel
lucky is what I feel as for awards
Leonardo
DiCaprio the global heartthrob finally
won Oscar gold for the Revenant after
losing five times before he also snagged
a sag award and a globe for the role
this was a hard movie to finance it was
a hard movie to make Leonardo DiCaprio
that was Leo's third Globe after the
Wolf of Wall Street I'm not used to this
type of thing to tell tell you the truth
and The Aviator how late will you party
when it's it's yours to celebrate I
don't know I I I'm I haven't e a single
thing all day I have a pulsating
headache right now cuz this the most
surreal weird experience I've ever had
in my life DiCaprio's co-stars I got to
work with some incredible actors all
around Hollywood's best Jack Nicholson
Robert dairo Merill Street Tom Hanks and
of course Kate Winslet I've got you I
won't let go and Leo's not letting go of
his number one collaborator Direct ctor
Martin scorsi we do have similar tastes
the duo has made six movies together
most recently killers of the flower Moon
he has range and he keeps growing Leo's
other passion word on the street has
always been Leo that you were a bit of a
hip-hop head and we saw that at your
party I have a range of musical love
that goes back to our stuff from the 20
30s and 40s with jazz and blues and then
hip-hop too fans got a glimpse of 's
rapping skills in this TMZ video but for
years we've watched him be an advocate
for the planet did you come here in a
Prius tonight yes I did Leo produced the
solution focused doc the 11th hour and
also to raise climate change awareness
he starred in 2021s don't look up
climate change is compromising the very
livability of our planet it's not only
about you know practicing this in your
everyday life but it's about voting
properly and while we always knew Leo
was destined to be a superstar at age 18
he told ET this the whole Hollywood
scene isn't exactly my thing I don't
like uh tshm and all that born in 1974
in Hollywood Leo was surrounded by the
entertainment industry my earliest
memories were of wanting to be an actor
I was in such close proximity to be able
to go on auditions after school early on
in his career an agent told Leo to
change his name to Lenny Williams why
Leonardo DiCaprio apparently sounded too
ethnic he declined and got his first
acting Credit in 1979 appearing in an
episode of Romper Room he would go on to
do plenty of commercials I did my first
television commercial when I was 13
years old and I got I got my S card very
proud day he was equally proud to land a
gig on the new Lassie his paycheck
$414 a day after that Leo appeared on TV
hits like Roseanne Parenthood and I
almost got the ones without the happy
hog but they were kind of Stuffy his
breakout role on Growing Pains I mean
Big Show big people big they've been
with each other for so long you know I
didn't know how they feel about me
coming in but they were really nice
about it while on that show Leo got his
first big feature film break in This
Boy's Life starring opposite Robert
dairo how big is this turkey going to be
thank God I can move on to something
like this now and be respected as an
actor and not not have been set in that
as the Public's mind frame as a series
actor or a Teen Idol or anything like
like that because it's not something I
want to be so you're Gilbert cuz I'm
Gilbert his next movie was with another
big star Johnny Depp in What's Eating
Gilbert Grape it earned Leo his very
first Oscar Na and while Leo lost out he
was kind of relieved I remember being
really paranoid about ever having to go
up in front of a billion people I just
don't want to go up there that's what I
remember my boy daddy this my boy right
here in 1994 ET was with the actor his
co-star Mark Wahlberg and his mom her on
the New York set of Basketball Diaries
he's great he's
cooler I'm just going to enjoy it while
it lasts because it may not last forever
that Year Leo also filmed the quick and
the dead and showed ET his gunslinging
skills a lot of different things we
could do with this thing but as for the
future Playboy skills as a heartthrob C
Leo's 1996 hit Romeo and Juliet ET
caught him on set kissing CLA Dan and
trying not to crack
up
Romeo and Juliet there's a heck of a lot
of kissing I mean he's actually amazing
at what he does she's a ball of emotion
a Powerhouse as I like to put
it their RedHot Romance movie rocketed
to number one grossing 147 million it
only cost 14.5 million to make when a
movie actually of yours hits number one
is a different thing you know people
come out of the woodwork you know that
you wouldn't have expected calling you
to do movies for them but it was 1997's
Titanic that cemented Leo's leading man
status I'm the king of the
world king of the world um is that the
term yeah never live that one up
down this film is going to be one that
they're going to like hold for future
Generations because it's it's truly an
epic in every sense of the word it's a
dope movie for sure Leo was just 21 when
he landed the role of Jack Dawson after
Johnny Depp turned it down director
James Cameron says Leo almost passed on
it too I've always had a prejudice
against doing like a big budget monster
film like that if it wasn't um a big
budget film I probably would have done
it anyway cuz the love story is so
great it's been rough hats off to all
those action guys cuz it's it's hard
stuff harder than I ever imagin I'm up
on like this tilting poop deck that's up
in Hydraulics I'm like 300 ft in the air
looking down at like thousands of people
falling below me you have to take a
moment out and say how the hell did I
get to this place in my life but the
hard work paid off Titanic was number
one at the box office for a record 15
consecutive weeks and it's made over $2
billion I sat next to the prince hung
out with him we chilled what did you
guys talk about oh he just wanted to
know about the different stunts it
reminded him of how it was in the Navy
he
said you you didn't come as a couple
tonight did you yeah we came together
we're good buddies absolutely just F but
thanks in part to his undeniable
chemistry with Kate the movie became a
pop culture phenomenon and Leo Mania was
born you got chased through the lube I
was like whizzing by the Mona Lisa 15 M
an hour truth of the matter is I'm like
I said I'm I'm very lucky and anytime I
hear myself complaining about anything
having to do with my life I I make I
make myself
nauseous Leo followed up Titanic playing
twins ET was on the French set of the
Man in the Iron Mas it's actually quite
comfortable after a while you get used
to it but the most horrible thing was
the fact that I mean I got itches on my
face but the uh
Chewbacca setup is a little difficult
Leo was on double duty again in 2002 as
an Irish excon in Gangs of New York and
a teenage con artist in Catch Me If You
Can please I mean it's my midterm next
week and my books are stolen ironically
in this movie I'm 28 years old and I'm
12 years a senior of the actual
character that I'm playing who's 16
years old he's not including his regular
guys Leo does his homework when it comes
to changing his voice he did a Boston
accent in The Departed every weekend s
it was just a matter of being able to
hang out with some people from Boston a
southern draw in D Jango Unchained Rosco
a beer for the man with a beard and a
South African accent in
diamond we fought and died together you
know you know I went there a month early
just to sort of hang out with the locals
and let them get drunk and tell me their
stories Leo's Transformations taking on
real life roles have earned him critical
Acclaim this is incredible he won a
Golden Globe and was nominated for an
Oscar for his portrayal of eccentric
billionaire Howard Hughes not only did
he star in The Aviator he produced this
8-year passion project he told us it
took one week to shoot that nude scene
you get to know the crew and you feel
comfortable in your birthday suit after
a while but it never got comfortable
wearing false teeth a bald cap and
colored contact to become J G Hoover it
became incredibly uh claustrophobic
after a while there were over 50 50
different intricate little pieces that
they glued on every day it was a 6-hour
process fast forward 2 years to 2013 Leo
brought a literary icon to life in The
Great
Gatsby I'm Gatsby that same year he
showed us his Wild outside and dance
moves as Financial criminal Jordan bort
in The Wolf of Wall Street and it was
just this sort of hedonistic atmosphere
on set but you felt like you know you
were a rock star you be
[Music]
relentless from Wall Street to the wild
Leo battled a bear and finally won an
Oscar for the Revenant and if you were
wondering yes that gnarly beard was real
I had that beard for a year and a half
I'm just proud that we have a great
piece of art to show for
it could jack have fit on that door at
the end oh my gosh I thought it I
remember bulling my eyes out when I was
I have no comment
squee yeah no
comment uhhuh that's all the comment we
need and that wouldn't be the last time
it was brought up either cuz when Brad
and Leo finally teamed up a big screen
Bromance was born you buy a house in
town you don't rent Eddie O'Brien taught
me that this is a rare sort of
occurrence it really came naturally but
Brad and I as soon as we step into these
shoes it was one of the more easy sort
of natural fits that I think I've ever
experienced he's a good egg and I'm
really happy the restraining order was
lifted off of me and so we were able to
work again he throws one of the best
Tantrums ever laid down on film you
sitting there like a
b both Brad and Leo received critical
Acclaim for their performances but Brad
was always quick to give props to his
co-star and the Oscar goes
to Brad
Pit
Leo I'll ride on your coattails any day
man and the Golden Globe goes
to Brad Pit I wouldn't be here without
you man I thank
you still I would have shared the
raft never like go of course that was a
playful dig at Leo's Titanic co-star and
his number one work wife Kate Winslet we
we just like each other as people we
were really Bosom Buddies I'd work with
him again like that Kate would get her
wish 11 years later in Revolutionary
Road we' definitely aggressively looked
to work together again we're very lucky
uh you know we've never had a fight to
me she's the greatest actress of her
generation he is the best actor of his
generation and here we are a whole
generation later and look at him look at
him for me to get married now would take
a
[Music]
lot marriage would wouldn't be uh in in
even my realm but you know yeah not much
has changed for little Romeo nearly 30
years after that interview because when
it comes to being a Perpetual Hollywood
Bachelor Leo is a model citizen I'm just
a little
jerk are you a romantic guy um yeah I'd
say so you know when I'm alone with a
girl I'm you know I'm doing the baby
voices the whole thing all that
ridiculous stuff and I have a girlfriend
right now and um I'm pretty nice to her
I have to say that girlfriend then 22
year-old model Kristen Zang the two were
hand inand at the 1996 Romeo and Juliet
Premiere does this look good on looks
wonderful Leo was also linked to
supermodels like Naomi Campbell and
Helena Christensen in 2000 he told us he
wasn't looking for anything serious I'm
happy on my own right now I like it but
that all changed later that year when he
met the then 20-year-old model Jazelle
bin I'm absolutely happy and you know
why because my life is balanced the two
dated for 5 years and many thought
Jazelle was the one when Leo brought her
to the 2005 Oscars along with his mom
did you bring jaelle yeah we came and uh
I got him away from all this got her
away from all this madness they broke up
later that year then he began a new
romance with 20-year-old Israeli model
bar rafaeli could you ever imagine
having a high-profile wedding o I don't
know I don't even
know a high-profile wedding I'm still
not married right now they're on again
alagan relationship spanned 6 years
coming to an end for good in 2011 when
she was 25 and Leo was 36 and 25 years
old seems to be Leo's go-to breakup
marker it is kind of insane sometimes
Leo's 2017 romance with Nina Agdal and
his most recent long-term relationship
with Daisy Jones and the sixes Camila
Marrone also came to an end when they
hit 25 though earlier this year he was
linked to giigi Hadid who was 27 in 2020
Golden Globe host Ricky Jes publicly
roasted Leo for his dating habits Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood nearly 3 hours
long Leonardo DiCaprio attended the
premiere and by the end his date was too
old for him
so while Leo's dated a bevy of beauties
he's only made it red carpet official
with two girlfriends his parents heral
Lin and George are often his plus one to
big events who's your date tonight oh my
mother my mom's running around having
fun somewhere doing something I got to
bring my dad tonight which is awesome
the Oscar winner credits his parents for
his success they supported his decision
to drop out of high school to pursue an
acting career over the years ET has
talked to Leo about his family's
unwavering love and encouragement of the
things that my dad said to me very early
on is my only wish for you is to to have
an interesting life that you that
fulfills you we didn't have much but I
had parents that said look our our son
wants to do this this is his dream and
they drove me every day to auditions and
they supported me they're special people
special people he's willing to share the
spotlight with his mom and grandom both
made quick cameos in the beach I've
tried to get uh my
mom in uh every movie that I've done
also in Leo's Inner Circle Toby Maguire
Lucas hos Kevin Connelly and David
Blaine the reported self-proclaimed wolf
pack I have a good solid group of
friends that I've known for a long time
that you know I trust with my life the
guys became fast friends in the 90s
after running into each other at
auditions in 2013 Leo shared the screen
with his closest pal Toby in The Great
Gatsby a who was great working with Leo
we've been friends for almost 25 years
to be able to have a partnership and a
friend like Toby to enter into this
world with who's always going to have my
best intentions at heart and vice versa
somebody who I can always be honest with
was a huge benefit having a
retrospective of your life seems a
little bit weird to me but when you do
that you have to be honest about it well
mission accomplished then but believe it
or not there are even more layers to Leo
here's some things that you may not know
has George Lucas approached you about
playing Anakin Skywalker um approached
key word I don't I I you know we've
talked about it you know I'd consider it
yeah Leo turned down doing attack of the
Clones the role went to Hayden
Christensen another gig he said no to
hosting SNL but he did do a
cameo I flying
[Music]
Jack yes Rose yes you're flying and did
you know Leo is a member of The
Beehive there he is at the Renaissance
tour in LA on be's birthday and here he
is in London at another show back in May
but Leo's alltime
fave the huge Beatles fanatic so I've
listened to every album on Loop they're
the greatest band
[Music]
ever